darum ist in London ich bin in Berlin
und per Skype habe ich von ihr erfahren
warum sie dort ist ist nämlich auf der
Olympiade mit vielen anderen Youtubern
zusammen und das lustige ist die das
habe ich im Interview erfahren machen
untereinander auch so eine Art Olympiade
hallo darum hallo Christoph was hat sich
nach London verschlagen
London selbst und Olympia und auch
Youtube ganz viele Gründe und wie hängt
das zusammen diese drei
gründet das nennt sich in eigenen
creators im Welt landen und haben
insgesamt 100 Partner aus aller Welt
nach London geschickt um hier einfach
Videos über Olympia zu machen und über
London und einfach ganz viel Cross
Promotion und zusammenzuarbeiten und
solche Sachen das ist ja sensationell
würde ich jetzt sagen mit deinen Worten
genauso beschreiben und wen hast du denn
jetzt kennengelernt zum Beispiel du ich
habe ich bin mit Namen ganz schwierig
ja überwiegend Amerikaner was ich etwas
seltsam finde aber es sind eigentlich
sonst nur noch Franzosen da äh wir
Deutschen sind da und sonst ist auch
schon mau in Europa und aus Amerika halt
ganz viele Youtuber kennt man dann den
ein oder anderen
dann wen kennt man noch hier der von
Berli politicalist da okay und so ein
paar andere noch die man bestimmt auch
kennen wo ich nur jetzt wieder total
erneut bin okay was macht ihr da die
ganze Zeit dreht er zusammen Videos
guckt der Olympia oder hängt ihr
zusammen rum alles
bestellt wo natürlich alle rein wollen
weil das mega geil ist und ähm ansonsten
kollaborieren wir gehen zu spielen wenn
wir Tickets haben und bringen einfach so
die Tage rum und das ist eigentlich
ziemlich voll immer also man hat gut zu
tun auf jeden Fall was hast du denn von
der Olympiade mitbekommen ich war
gestern Beachvolleyball oh geil
mit hier dem deutschen Duo ich wusste
nicht wer spielt und habe dann gehört
Deutschland gegen Holland und wir sind
ausger
astet und die so gut gespielt und es hat
geregnet und wir saßen das ist halt Open
Air also ohne Dach ne aber das hat uns
den Spaß nicht genommen die Engländer
können gut feiern und das hat wirklich
Bock gemacht das war wirklich cool und
übermorgen ist Frauenfußball Japan gegen
USA aber du darfst da gar nichts drehen
oder so ich habe jedenfalls noch kein
Video gesehen wo irgendein Sportler zu
sehen war oder was was ähm nee darf ich
nicht wobei ich mich jetzt anfangen
werde dagegen zu werden weil die
Deutschen sind schon wieder die einzigen
die sich an die Regeln halten ah okay
überall Blocks von vom Stadion und
deswegen habe ich gestern auch eins
gedreht also es wird etwas zu Olympia
kommen sehr gut weil ähm wir wollen ja
sehen was du da erlebst eben aber die
Regeln haben erst dagegen gesprochen ich
musste etwas abwarten das ist so das
Olympische Komitee was da so streng ist
wir haben es ja schon erlebt auch bei
Kampfrichter Entscheidung die sind ja
manchmal peps sicher als der Papst oder
liegen komplett daneben die haben echt
krasse Regeln aufgestellt teilweise ja
das stimmt
okay wie lange bleibst du denn noch da
ich bin jetzt noch eine Woche da bis
nächsten Montag und die ist auch noch
ganz gut vollgepackt also es gibt noch
die machen immer kleine challenges
zwischendrin und es gibt noch Karten für
die Abschlusszeremonie zu gewinnen und
solche Dinge und mal schauen was da geht
okay challenges heißt jetzt zum Beispiel
mit dem Cap von A nach B fahren und sich
zu schminken will abzuschminken wieder
zu schminken und so weiter oder was nee
das war meine Challenge das ist zwischen
ein Youtuber die hier sind wer am
meisten ähm links auf dem äh wer am
meisten Klicks auf dem anderen Kanal
bringen kann wer die coolste
Kollaboration startet wäre Prozent am
meisten Dings und solche Sachen die halt
so Analytics mäßig gemessen werden
sozusagen okay das heißt ihr macht eure
eigene Youtube Olympiade
okay wer liegt vorne wir hatten ganz
viele challenges schon ganz viele Sachen
also ich glaube jeder hat bis jetzt
irgendwas mein Freund gut okay wir sind
auf eurem Medaillenspiegel gespannt
also ich gucke immer wo Deutschland
liegt
im Scrollbereich Deutschland liegt auf
der Olympia App im Scrollbereich sage
ich jetzt nur
okay ja dann viel Spaß noch in London
wir sind gespannt auf die weiteren
Videos und bis dann bleibt dran